i was like so bad at telling when people
are boning because i recently found out
someone in our group were these two were
hooking up and i'm like for real they're
like how can you not tell them like i
don't know
like i don't i'm so bad at telling well
sometimes you're not looking for it
though yeah exactly like yeah it was a
very odd couple too i'm like really yeah
oh that's cool and that probably also
shows that you don't see either one of
them that way yeah
tina
you are an unreliable source because i
have personally witnessed personally
myself witness
more than one guy
drool over you and you're like no
no there's no way he likes me no way if
we on the same page
we're on the same page he's in love with
you have you seen that trend where like
only girls know what these looks mean
and it's so subtle yes there's like the
yeah and then the yeah
you know so then you gotta tell your
friends i'm getting so much botox
because i can't
because i can't tell she looks surprised
the whole time are you so surprised
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
who do we have here today
nikki blaze our beautiful guest hi wow
and you have me gina hi yay she's
beautiful too she's so gorgeous
and me
she's beautiful too thank you thank you
thank you sorry if i ever have kids i
hope i look like you have to have kids
because i feel like
i'll be like nah i'm good i'm just be
huge
no [ __ ] tina's just gonna give up no
you know what's crazy i was full what
there was a fly that flew my face she
went full crosstalk
oh my god a little tiny little fruit
flying right now what the [ __ ]
i thought you were picking yourself like
postpartum or something you're like
no i was gonna say i was 100 fully
prepared to just be a completely
different body for the rest of my life
i could hear luca in the other room um
because i'm like oh i'm in my 30s
already like i i had isaac when i was
18. so yeah i just snapped right back
where i'm like okay that was just
because i was a teen
i'm fully prepared to be like a size 12
forever or something i don't know but
luckily i fit into all my old clothes
now six months later and i'm like what
maybe it's just good jeans that's tight
because my mom
didn't snap back so i just thought like
i was just gonna have the same
trajectory of like yeah you know body i
told my man i'm like if we if you want a
baby
or the men i've dated if you want a baby
then uh you're gonna like if you want me
to have your baby because i'm so like
scared of having babies already then
you're gonna pay for my uh mommy
makeover oh that's that's the deal that
we're making
i've been really optimistic my grandma
and my mom snapped back like my mom's
had five kids
still yeah body was popping but one
thing i was gonna say is that most of
the people that i know that i've had
babies like later on
their bodies actually look better if not
like they're smaller than they were
crazy baby yeah i don't know i think
it's just like the game's a little
different now you know we have access to
like just like such good food
and then you know more education not
convinced yeah you can't tell me no you
know it's crazy too i'm just trying to
be optimistic you know what i'm saying
we ain't got no kids yet but i'm i'm
just being hopeful that like we just
don't blame it society is better now
i don't know i can take all my vitamins
and
maybe maybe you know what i mean i'm a
breastfeed if i can
i think that's what it is it's the
breastfeeding it makes you like it makes
your uterus like shrink yeah i in six
months i still haven't worked out i just
went walking around the block for a few
times
like months ago but yeah i don't know i
think it's really the breastfeeding and
the better education of food
because
yeah like previous generations would be
like oh yeah butter so healthy
right
anyway we're not talking about that
today what we are talking about is um
adults are exposing the telltale signs
that people are having a sexual affair
so it's just like these little clues
that tell you that two people are
[ __ ] oh yeah
okay let's grab our coffees yeah okay
all right i love being something nosy
that's the jesus
all right so number one on this list it
says the two of them constantly being
the last ones left at the group hangout
especially one of them is hosting it's a
huge flag that they're involved
thousand percent anybody that's overly
helpful too
i wouldn't necessarily say that they're
sleeping together maybe that like one
wants to sleep with the other
okay so let's if it's not reciprocal
yeah maybe right because if you're just
kind of like watching i can't
necessarily like say oh yeah there's
definitely boning if they're just there
at the end okay but what if your
partner like you're waiting for your
partner and they're just like
helping one of their co-workers mm-hmm
and they're the last ones death
yeah die die die well i mean like paint
that like paint the scenario okay
because i'm trying to envision this play
out so it's like you're seeing someone
and like one of the one of their
co-workers is throwing the event and
your partner decides to stay longer to
help them out would that automatically
make you be concerned about their french
their relationship no not really i think
it's just like i mean especially like
our relationship if it's strong and like
we're just being polite because i help
clean up but i don't like stay all the
way to the end you know say they stay
till they end very very very very end
yep depends on how close they are yeah
okay i feel like there needs to be other
clues too like are they like lingering
looks is it like kind of like brushing
kind of touches every time everyone
laughs they look at each other yeah
that's actually on here oh yeah see yeah
see yeah that's one of the signs okay so
we're not saying it's a guarantee yet
but that could be something that might
hint at maybe you got to add a few of
those things up on the list and then
okay yeah i feel like just helping yeah
yourself if it's because it could also
be just part of the personality like
they're just very helpful people and
culture yeah and culture okay so we'll
say that this is kind of like not
extremely red maybe this is like a white
pinkish color flag yeah it's a pink flag
okay
but yeah another portion of that first
one it says i know someone is about to
bone when my friend says for everyone to
leave and the new friend they invited
doesn't move an inch oh oh yeah that
situation of course yeah of course they
ain't going nowhere all right everybody
leave you stay
have you ever have you ever been in the
situation where you knew everybody else
was having to go and you were going to
stay not saying you're in a relationship
but just say like you're dating someone
and not everybody else knows that you
guys are talking
kind of yes yeah yeah kind of yes um god
i know i've been i just don't remember
what exactly happened but yes i do
remember being in that situation and
then everyone kind of got it oh like uh
when i went out with my best friend and
this guy
and like we kept on extending the night
because it was our first time kind of
like meeting and hanging out and
everything and she can tell that we
liked each other
and then she's like
um
it's getting late it's like oh yeah yeah
we should go home and then she like me
and the guy looked at her like
yeah
and she's like oh uh i i gotta go pick
up my boyfriend from something oh why
don't you drive gina home yes
there we go yeah so that she picked up
on it yeah and she's like come on gina
mm-hmm let's go gina i know exactly
amy shut the [ __ ] up baby amy go home
amy don't you have a home to go home
today don't you have a house yeah you
have a house right don't you have a plan
to go water
[Laughter]
you got things to do leave yeah that is
really obvious have you guys ever seen
that happen yeah
for sure i've been that person i've also
seen it happen to where i've had to pick
up on the like well i'm going to excuse
myself and then there's nothing
funnier than knowing it and then you
make it awkward sometimes that's like
the highlight of it
you know like you're the one saying or
you're the one no no you're leaving and
you know like your friend is staying
because they like someone you're like oh
okay so i'm taking it that i'm going to
go soon
by myself apparently am i going i'm
going home
[ __ ]
oh my god i'm going home alone did you
bring me you know what that's fine it's
okay
get it bye i think it's so cute too
because actually the last time this
happened and the guy and i weren't
hooking up or anything i have a friend
who's a dj and he was performing in
chicago and uh all of g4 was also in
chicago for a convention
um so he's one of the djs for adventure
club right and then so he's like oh [ __ ]
i'm in town bring your friends my my
co-workers my co-host love adventure
club and then so we go and then the
show's over we're all hanging out in the
green room having fun it's like two in
the morning and like they're getting
tired and i'm talking to my friend but
they're like what do we
do what do we do because we're all
shit-faced and then one of them finally
came over to me and said we don't know
if we should leave you or not
because
like are you safe
yeah they're scared for my safety right
oh shout out good friends yeah yeah i
love them shout out to austin creed and
fiona good friends um are you safe are
you good and i'm like yeah i'm drunk i'm
like yeah no i'm good they're like are
you sure i'm like so i had to like pull
myself together and be like oh no dude
don't worry i've known this guy for like
six years yeah you know and then they're
like are you hooking i'm like no we're
not looking at this just the homie we're
friends and it was fine but it was the
cutest thing because i saw them kind of
like dawdling around like because like
like they want to go but they didn't
know what to do you know
those are good friends have you ever
been in a situation though where your
friend is like they want to go and the
other person doesn't want your friend to
go and then you're trying to help them
get out of the situation
i was one of those i've seen that before
why didn't she want her to go yeah
well she was she thought she was down
and then she wasn't down oh
yeah like that like they were initially
supposed to hang out and then she
changed her mind halfway through that's
an awkward situation to be in yeah but
it's happened before we need a code word
is what it is everything always
yeah or i mean usually it's a look yeah
there's been times where i've had to
look at my friend and be like girl you
you giving me a cross side i'm confused
what does that look like
she's like she i've been i've been given
mixed signals before from a friend i'm
like girl do you want me to help you
leave or do you want me to help you stay
like i'm really confused
like pull her aside like we have to go
to the bathroom yeah yeah
girl what are you doing or not like
where are these looks she's like i don't
know i'm like you don't know me i don't
know yeah i can't help you
have you seen that trend where like only
girls know what these looks mean and
it's so subtle yes there's like the
yeah and then the yeah
you know so then you gotta tell your
friends i'm getting so much botox
because i can't
because i can't tell she looks surprised
the whole time
[Applause]
[Music]
you need the wrinkles the wrinkles tell
the story
girl
now everybody's confused in l.a we don't
know how to do this anymore i think
you're like trying to make the face back
like
buddy holy [ __ ] oh my god because we've
all been there you know you know you've
seen that friend and be like oh [ __ ] we
ain't gonna know what's gonna happen
today yeah
it's so funny
oh my god
you know it's funny talking about this
like i'm trying to because i haven't
been in these situations in like 10
years like i haven't been in a in a in a
club environment like single friends
like just like other people i'm just
like in my own bubble so i'm like what
was that like i can't remember it just
seems like a whole life time ago it's
funny it's hilarious because you're
talking about these situations i'm like
i feel like i've witnessed that maybe
maybe in a movie like i don't remember
it in my own life you probably went
through it i mean like 10 years ago you
know it probably was so long yeah i
wrote them down that idea i'm going to
make a tick talk about it later
thank you for that i'm recording you got
it so funny
all right number two on this list
they almost always try too hard to hide
it like if they go to an arcade with
their co-workers they'll play different
games but right besides each other
instead of just playing together or
they'll flirt with total strangers at
the bar area or they'll freak out if
people think they're flirting and other
stuff like that
or it's like
why are you so defensive the
overreacting yeah
over overreacting yeah i i think i read
somewhere that people found out that
these two were hooking up at work
because
um they both came in at kind of separate
times but they both smelled the same oh
yeah like there's like a certain smell
it wasn't like a bad smell necessarily
but like there's like a like maybe like
a scent shampoo or something yeah
something like that yeah
that's also kind of weird how people
smelled them
maybe the shampoo's really strong like
kasim i can smell him a mile away
because he uses moroccan oil shampoo i
love that smell
there's like okay so
one of my co-workers has a very distinct
like um hand
spray that they use
so it's so distinct that if i would have
smelt it on someone else i would have
been like oh were you hanging out with
so-and-so so i think that's what
happened because some people just have
like a you know a smell yeah odors is a
bad word
like a scent yes they have a sound about
them since it's nice like an aroma i'm
saying is that an over and over some
people got an odor a stench right
on you they're punjabi
that's so gross is that like moist for
you guys like that it's just like
distorted people it's just when it
subscribes if i hear the word pungent
i'm thinking in in like the general
genital region
yeah you know like a little funk that's
so funny
i remember going through like middle
school or high school when you're going
through your period and you're still
trying to learn how to like
and the smell is so strong and i'm like
in class i'm like
[Laughter]
and like you like you don't know like
how often you change your pad in middle
school
you know so i'm like do i wear the same
one all day
no
i was raised in a house full of men
okay
and she was rough yeah i could do that
if you can relate please leave a comment
it's my truth i'm speaking my truth
speak your truth
speak your truth sister somebody out
there is probably going oh my god i'm
not alone i have a general rule i have a
general rule now that i tell it all role
a general rule and a general rule okay
the rule is if you can smile yourself a
little assume that everyone can smell
you a lot yeah yeah that's a good one
write that down put it on a shirt
everyone needs to know that that would
be a hilarious those of you who go to
[ __ ] conventions oh
they can't smell themselves psa dude
that's crazy put it on a shirt you know
the only time i tend to smell myself is
when i'm making a a writer like i forgot
which one a turn in my car and you get
the smell of your own hair
how are you driving you're having a box
no you you know you've smelled this you
know you have because i know i'm not
alone i mentioned it once a long time
ago and people were like yeah i know
what you're talking about but yeah like
i think it's a left turn when you make a
left turn like somehow you get your own
like cut odor get your wife get your
such a whiff of your own hair when i was
dog dancing was always
yeah
[ __ ]
i saw this video clip of a girl in the
concert she was like
oh yeah
god bless her god bless alicia's aware
she can smell herself she keeps it down
and literally you realize your armpit
smell you hug someone you're like hey oh
my goodness okay question
would you tell
your friends if they didn't smell good
[Music]
man boogers yes
yes would you tell would you tell each
other yes okay yes
i give you guys full permission to tell
me if i don't smell good
like i think you in your friend group
you should give your friends permission
yeah yes so that
you not out in these streets being
stanky yeah not just that but like when
something's off yeah like if something
like i have freaking
i don't know like makeup on my cheek or
something or
i don't know there's something in my
teeth
like just be like
something booger yeah something do you
think that you have to give your friends
permission to do that so they don't i
think soccer's not because other people
are yeah you know or you know they might
they don't want to make it awkward yeah
but then you should they might feel
awkward by you bringing it up even
though you're trying not to make them
feel awkward because then they'll get
offended some people get offended true
where it's like that's a yeah that's a i
learned a rule when i was like nine
years old where uh it said i've read in
a random ass book that said if someone
offers you gum or mint just always say
yes yeah yeah even if they're just
trying to be nice yeah always say yes
just in case because it might be their
way of saying right write that down too
yes yes yes yes yes
y'all are taking notes today mm-hmm yeah
take the notes even though this video is
life can get kind of overwhelming and
these feelings can make it kind of hard
to shift gears and get in the mood with
dipsy you can focus on what makes you
feel good dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on
find stories about that intriguing
co-worker with a british accent or
hooking up with your hot yoga instructor
new content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore
dipsy also has sleep stories wellness
sessions and now they also offer written
stories it's your go-to place to spice
up your me time explore your fantasies
or heat things up with a partner for
listeners of the show dipsy is offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipsystories.com
mood
that's 30 full days of access for free
when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a stories dot
com slash mood again that's
gypsystories.com
mood do you order from doordash but wish
you didn't have to pay delivery fees
well dreams do come true during summer
of dash pass you can save money and
enjoy new members only offers every week
on top of zero delivery fees all year
round say hello to summer savings during
the summer of dash pass from doordash
with zero delivery fees exclusive items
and more than 25 000 members only offers
nationwide dash pass by doordash has
everything you need to make your summer
memorable with your dash pass by
doordash membership you can save an
average of four to five dollars on every
order you place for delivery or pickup
that means on average dash pass pays for
itself when you order just twice a month
and you know i definitely order at least
once or twice a week so i'll hit that
with members only offers and items
dropping every week you'll have
everything you need to make the most out
of summer right at your fingertips shine
bright during doordash's summer of dash
pass and get 50 off your first order up
to a 15 value use promo code mood at
checkout when you spend 12 or more
that's 50 off your first order up to a
15 value when you sign up for doordash
using summer of dash pass using promo
code mood don't forget that's code mood
for 50
off your first order up to a 15 value
dash pass benefits only on eligible
orders that meet the minimum subtotal
terms apply all right number three the
little conversational clues like when
two people glance knowingly each other
frequently at each other frequently or
have friendly little side whispers
because they have their own thing going
on apart from the group and they hover
near each other to be physically close
all those little examples of intimacy
are the only that they're all the that
that are only between them yeah yeah for
sure like what's so funny
yeah why are you guys laughing so hard
right let us know what's going on here
yeah inside joke when did you have time
to make this inside show yeah that that
is that's the thing right there was like
when did you find the time because i'm
pretty sure i talked to you all goddamn
date so what the [ __ ] is so funny yeah i
thought we all hanging out together one
of you guys hang out solo to make these
inside jokes i don't know about your
jealous friends yeah yeah when the [ __ ]
did you get some friends no listen to
this one a married
a married ex-friend of mine once started
showing up with a woman and acting like
that i could tell they were banging and
i couldn't believe he wasn't trying
harder to conceal it turns out the poor
woman had no idea he was married and was
unaware that everyone else did know
it was later traumatizing to her to
realize that she had been seen as a
mistress when she was the only person
who didn't know what was really
happening she's not a friend of mine
he's not i wonder how it came out how
she found out
you know people can tell if you're a
good person or not and i feel like
sometimes if you
if the people around can
pick up that you don't know what the
hell is going on
somehow the the truth will get to you i
think
people can pick up on that yeah it's
either it might either be that or the
opposite where someone is so appalled by
your
yeah you're one of the other yeah but
your behavior with like how could you be
a [ __ ] home wrecker yeah yeah and
then she finds out yeah
i was like so bad at telling when people
are boning because i recently found out
someone in our group were these two were
hooking up and i'm like for real they're
like how can you not tell them like i
don't know
like i don't i'm so bad at telling well
sometimes you're not looking for it
though yeah exactly like yeah it was a
very odd couple too i'm like really yeah
oh that's cool and that probably also
shows that you don't see either one of
them that way yeah
i think that's what it also like
yeah you probably don't think about them
boning true yeah
all right number four i saw venmo
payments for grocery items even toilet
paper which i thought was too personal
of an item to be sharing expenses with
non with a non-roommate
what
it was between two co-workers or two
work friends who for a long time denied
that they were dating and claimed that
they were just really good friends
turned out turns out that they'd been
together for months by then yes let me
tell you i feel like i am
such a huge fan of guys doing like
domestic things for me i
[ __ ] love it so like buying groceries
or like sending little stuff here and
there just like
things that you wouldn't necessarily
think are like romantic
one thousand percent and i for sure was
thinking with that person so yeah yeah
getting ven mode for toilet paper oh my
god i love like baby
baby you're sending me to make sure my
ass is clean i know right so you can eat
it later that is so sweet it might be
for you
it's for us
our future
no i feel like i've stopped i've stalked
venomous before because i was like oh
[ __ ] dating this guy i'm like oh [ __ ]
you think scoffing looks like you
stalked venmos oh yeah wait side note
easy
i take it back it's been a while since
i've been crazy yes i have yeah it's
it's been a minute it's been a minute
but yes i thought you said you stopped
venmo
stop don't come out of her mouth no
there's no stopping here we don't quit
okay
you know what i hate about venmo though
it makes you friend everyone that's ever
been in your phone where i'm like
not for me well for me maybe it's like
early venmo but all my venmo feed is
from people that i literally i just
saved their number and my phone once for
like a random contact in like years ago
and i see their [ __ ] pop i'm like how do
i understand people that might be a
setting because i don't have that at all
oh that would be a really good way like
if you're getting into a relationship
with someone checking their venmo yep
because you can even see like who
they've gone to lunch with yeah who do
they interact with if you see that name
pop up all the time like why are you and
vanessa always going out to lunch and
then he's like
she's my therapist
so why she paid for her hat i know so
i'm just picking up anyways i just want
to see what his nice girlfriend looks
like i'm like oh she's
cute but then like we were just laying
in bed one day it's like oh let me show
you this picture and her picture popped
up on my my feet or on my my uh my phone
oh
why did it pop up on her because i see
why would you say to show my friends in
the group chat i mean like look we were
all crazy at one point okay
okay like you delete it you yeah i don't
know
but then it was like dude she's actually
really cute and then like my friend's
like oh she's really cute i'm like oh
that's sweet this was like from like two
years ago they were dating right before
us we're going through the phone oh let
me show you this picture and then her
picture pops up i was like
yeah how'd you play that off would you
say what did you do what'd you say what
did you do what did you say is that my
ex i was just honest i'm like listen i
was just curious yeah
there's no way to go
girl
yeah we just want to know because to
really tell the the
crazy level is to see what you would
have said yeah exactly right yeah and
then so i was like you know what like
girls are curious and then he was
understanding he's like trust me i get
it we do it in the boys chat too like
everyone gets curious i'm like oh did
you make out
oh i just let my crazy out oh feel so
good
i'm accepted for my crazy right
goals thank you that's funny
but yeah for sure that's a definite way
to tell somebody about yeah baby why are
you sending her toilet paper
right
all right number five
oh my god oh my god would you ever write
that did you ever that's that's what you
do to your friends when you're messing
around
yeah imagine though that would be
hilarious and i see you i see payments
like for the strippers last night or
something yeah like that i always said
my friends like for the dick yeah just
for the dick that's it just but if it's
toilet paper that's serious yeah no one
joked around with that yeah number five
when your significant other brings
someone up way too much in the beginning
then mysteriously stops talking about
them at all even when the situation
potentially calls for it that could be a
sign that they were [ __ ]
that's a tough one
i would say that's a hard well okay the
being awkward about their name later on
yeah yeah yeah that would be like the
like
why are you not bringing why are you or
like going out of your way to not bring
them up now yeah i heard like um there's
ones like when they
go out of their way to talk [ __ ] about
her like oh damn this girl so yeah yeah
she's like the most annoying and like
they're for sure sleeping yeah yeah
that's what nicki nicki said about her
ex when he was cheating on her with her
his co his co-worker that he would talk
[ __ ] about her too all the time
because they try to like
they try to throw you off the scent yeah
it just makes it more obvious yeah
it's weird trash yep how did okay can
you guys tell the difference between
oh maybe i'm just gonna go grab lunch
with um kevin
and oh maybe i'm just gonna go grab
lunch with a friend
you
yeah you omitted for a reason yeah the
name of the person
who you're going and because then if
they ask oh really what friend
then what do you say after that yeah
oh you know just a friend like i've
known him for a while you know like it's
always like whenever they say a friend
like that gets a little bit um yeah as
someone who has said that before
not that i was cheating but i realized
that i didn't say it because i didn't
want to have to explain myself
it wasn't just comes off sleazy yeah and
even if you don't mean it yeah because
it was like it wasn't intentional but it
was just like okay and then when they
asked i was like oh it's so-and-so yeah
then i've noticed i was like oh
that sounds real suspicious sneaky yep
why didn't you just say it in the first
place yeah avoidant behavior is like why
are you being avoided there's a reason
behind that whether or not it's it's
malicious right you gotta investigate
why are you being avoidant yeah so if
you have a tendency to do that catch
yourself before you have to explain
yourself put that put that on a shirt
catch yourself before you have to
explain yourself
that's good another shirt another shirt
we got a lot of shirts this episode
just start a whole little thing next one
is number six i've caught people because
they didn't follow one another on social
media to try to avoid suspicion but they
they then posted
the same stuff at the like similar
places similar photos
despite not posting about one another it
was obvious they didn't know what the
other was posting because they didn't
follow one ano another which ultimately
led to the downfall of their discretion
this is what i read about with um
uh in um on social media some account
that shade the shade room
yeah they pointed out um
michael b jordan and then the girl he
was dating harvey laurie
how they were at the same vacationing at
the same place they weren't posting
about each other yeah girl was like oh
yeah that was like
that is so that's some rookie [ __ ] yeah
that is i mean she [ __ ] that up and
you know what and it's normally the
people in the friend groups too
like everybody can tell when you post is
if you're posting your location or if
you just post that you're outside people
can put two and two together normally
most people are dating within like a
certain circle yeah so it's only
inevitable that people are going to find
out then you have those around you that
don't know if you're being sneaky and
then they post their [ __ ]
so if you think by not following
somebody means that nobody's going to
find out that you're [ __ ] somebody
that's dumb yeah it's 20 22.
this reminds me of when casey and i
first started dating we were following
each other but we were very
like
we would
we would communicate about what we would
post and we would make sure to not post
each other because we just didn't want
to put like we were still like dating we
weren't like boyfriend girlfriend like
trying to put it out there that we were
together because yeah like we did have
like similar friends
and
yeah i remember that like intentionally
trying to avoid the fact that we were
together but still posting at the same
places right i was talking to this guy
and i had asked about this girl and he
goes
it's not the ones you see you need to
ask about hmm
[Music]
interesting let's take it that we're not
talking but that was a valid point
because he was like why because we were
talking
and he was like if you can see her
that's not who you need to be worried
about but then also i was like the fact
that you're telling me this
yeah
but which was true i've i've learned
that talk to enough guys they'll be like
it's never the ones you see in the
comments
every once in a while you'll see that
because there'll be a trend like if
you're trying to spot if somebody's
talking if you're going the social media
route it's normally pretty subtle
it's it's the like maybe maybe a comment
here and there and then they're kind of
consistent with that or there's like an
inside type of emoji or whatever but
most of the time a lot of these guys are
talking to girls that are not even
following um that's true because like
whenever
i post my guy friends it's just full
face whatever i'm hanging out i tag him
but when i'm like
soft opening
a boyfriend you know just like a soft
launch yeah it's a little soft launch
you know you get like an elbow
never tagged never tagged no or the tag
is hidden or there's like just a plate
yeah
yeah that's cool
that's not the one you got to worry
about but the ones where i'm posting
full face yeah i might be hugging him
right nothing
if i tag him all the time there's
nothing going on yeah
damn
all right this is the next one
it's so funny it's so funny
okay especially with the friends that
already know yeah who you're dating yeah
you'd be like oh yeah
i've done it i've done it like then all
of a sudden there's like a winky face
you'd be like oh that [ __ ] knows what's
going on
yeah you'll be in the comments going oh
she knows wait oh i don't even go in the
comments i do a dm because yeah that's
how slick i am yeah i'm like yeah yeah
real real friends hit you in the dms oh
my gosh shout out to my real friends
everyone smile they'd be doing that be
like [ __ ] no
yes
no yes all right number seven this is
from my personal experience i was
hooking up with a co-worker and she'd
bring her dog into the office her dog
started sitting under my desk every day
and we were exposed oh
that's cute that's adorable when pets
love you i love that yeah
except onyx is a [ __ ] he loves
everybody so
he'll be underneath everybody so that's
a great way to catch someone cheating
too like that yeah
they run over to them like why
how does the dog know who you are why
are you connected to my wi-fi already
that's the one oh yeah
oh god that's the dead giveaway yeah by
the way did you change your wifi
password because i'm not connected to
your wi-fi anymore um
something happened where everything
reset
it's the same password okay yeah
that's super funny you're like by the
way you must be seeing someone new yeah
what happened what happened to the
password i'm not connected i have no
bars you got new friends
you got new friends i'm using my data
how dare you
that's how you know it's over yeah
you want to know what's over when you no
longer can connect to their wi-fi before
they change their wi-fi password with
you damn imagine that that's the
ultimate it's like change your netflix
password change the wi-fi that was me
i was still using my x's netflix for a
while he even changed his name to hi
tiffany
oh [ __ ] that's hilarious
oh wow
i was like okay fine i'll dip out so
funny i guess it's over
i remember a guy and i broke up for a
little bit and got back together and in
between like we were dating other people
and when we got back together i was
hanging out with this place looking and
i was like
were you still using my [ __ ] he's like
yeah i'm like you were using my [ __ ]
[ __ ] other girls watch okay
oh what was funny when my ex and i
separated
and we were still friends i tried to log
into netflix monday and i got kicked out
so i said oh so we really doing this now
and he goes my sister which i didn't
realize we were on his sister's account
my sister changed the password here's
the new thing
he was like he's like here's the new
password you're psycho he's like
thank you
that's so funny i saw a reddit post
about this person being petty because
they knew that their boyfriend was still
using their netflix account and he was
watching the show and she saw on social
media he was holding a season finale
party
oh yeah i think i saw this yeah yeah and
then right like five minutes before the
show started she signed off all accounts
oh that no i thought you were going to
say that she ended up um texting him or
telling him somehow the spoiler oh
of a show that he started watching yeah
i knew it was really over
when i had to start having all my own
accounts
you know when i was like a big girl and
like wasn't even on my parents netflix
anymore you know or i feel like you uh
you know it's really sad when nobody's
bugging you for your password
you're like you know that you're not
loved or have no friends and family when
you have your own account yeah there's
like no other accounts when you know
like when you log into gina
brother mom oh so you're by yourself
yeah when i made my paramount plus
because nobody wants this paramount
exactly nobody wants paramount plus
because
i got it for twilight zone and then once
i finished it i stopped watching yeah
that's how i knew i was like oh i'm
single
nobody else watches my [ __ ] with me
nobody wants to share my password all
right
all right number eight they stopped
saying thank you to each other got
caught myself with that once
actually i always in the movie love
actually i always thought it was a
profound observation of the writers when
emma thompson's character finds out her
husband is cheating because his mistress
served him a drink at a party and he
didn't say thank you it was subtle but
they made a real effort to not reach to
each other react to each other another
one said house and house md had a
similar line with
that nurse brought you a coffee and you
didn't thank her that only happens when
you're real intimate with someone oh
because it just feels expected
i get i don't know because i was reading
this and i'm like can't relate i try to
say thank you to
every time but is it because they're
trying so hard to not draw attention to
them that they do too much i think it's
kind of oh i think they're overly trying
to be like because i'm like if you're
really intimate with someone i hope
you're still saying thank you yeah
but this way i think like they're just
trying to hide it like you're not
interacting at all you have to interact
like normally socially yeah but to not
interact at all and that's weird yeah
cause then you come off route then it's
like why and then maybe that's where the
questions start that's a weird one yeah
it makes sense but it is
a weird yeah well these are so subtle
yeah
crazy number nine the thing that has
gotten myself and others busted is
changing how we interact with each other
at the office which is what we're
touching on right now in the lead-up to
dating a co-worker there's usually
flirty behavior between the two people
it's not inappropriate but it has a
certain energy when you actually start
dating your co-worker and the two of you
want to keep it quiet i have noticed
some people myself included will try to
out-clever themselves and tone down
their flirtatious behavior at work well
that's a change and changes in behavior
make something more noticeable we
thought we were being spies about it i
got my wake-up call literally when there
was a work emergency and her boss called
my phone in the morning he asked if she
was there because he couldn't get a hold
of her i was all why are you asking me
and his response was relax everyone
knows you're not exactly subtle now is
she there because i need her it was a
wake-up call that people that the people
you're with every day notice [ __ ] for
yeah sure yeah humans like patterns and
when the pattern is disrupted we notice
yeah being in an office now you would be
able to tell like you can feel the
energy in a room even if somebody's like
upset with another person or like you
know whoever's spending time like who's
actually friends who's like not just
work friends you can pick up on all of
it yeah like the whole vibes like the
whole energy vibes whatever that's a
real thing that we all are tuned to oh
my god and people who deny that it's
like you're just you're not very present
with yourself well you ain't been in a
room full of people that don't like each
other then because it is
when you say you can cut the tension
with a knife that is such a real feeling
and then you can tell
when something is off
you pick a body oh yeah it's crazy i
remember when i was 21 i worked at a bar
it was like a vietnamese bar as a
cocktail waitress and the owner was this
woman she was real nice at first and all
of a sudden she's like
something shifted and i was like what
what's going on and then i told my
co-worker i was like i don't think she
likes me very much out of nowhere and i
helped her like open like i was one of
the first waitresses and then i told my
um co-worker that and she wouldn't go to
the boss
and the boss was like hey i heard that
you think i don't like you why would you
think that i'm like i don't know it just
feels kind of weird later on it turns
out
she was cheating on her um husband who
helps her run the bar on the bar she was
cheating on him and she got hyper
um like suspicious paranoid paranoid
because like she's projecting yeah yeah
so she thought that he was sleeping with
all the waitresses
and i'm like i'm just trying to go to
work she can confess this to you no no
so later on we found out yeah because
she just up and left with one of the
patrons and because she met this guy
while you know working there and she's
up and left with him he just thumbs up
damn
the guilt got together patterns man
people paid yeah
really do damn really do
oh these are good yeah number 10 they
make sure to not leave a place together
but one of them will always linger
around long enough to know when the
other is leaving and they look at each
other when something funny or bad
happens
man you can feel that eye contact from a
mile away you if you suspect that
somebody is like interested in another
person they're always going to find a
way to connect no matter what there's
always
always yeah especially when you're
trying to hide it you can't hide
like that's the hardest part you know
it's like sometimes you don't want
people in your business and i mean like
resp
you know it's hard when you're dating
somebody and you don't want everyone all
up in your [ __ ] right and you try to be
like low-key and you're like you know
you're texting each other and you can
you can also tell too another thing is
like if you see someone look down
and then look at the person and look at
that person
yeah
yeah one of the first things they'll do
is they'll look at the person that
texted them
that's like one sign if you're trying to
figure out like who's talking to who
or if you're like you send a text and
they don't look at you and they look
somewhere else you're like
wait who's texting you yeah you know
like who's texting us i definitely us
i've done that with like my girlfriends
before like i've sent a text and you
know you're weird low-key trying to be
sneaky and we're talking about something
like
[ __ ] i texted you who wait what are you
talking to and then you're over here
like
hey hey come here come here no no we're
not even playing nobody come here
the hell are you talking to
cause i thought we was no you oh
okay you walk away i hate when
like you're trying to give someone like
a subtle nudge on their table you kick
them they're like what oh yeah
or when someone's trying to get someone
else's attention and they kick you and
you're like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you yeah they're like
oh
that wasn't for you over like oh sorry
that's funny that's for you
yeah these are all like you like real
subtle signs but all basic psychology
right yeah it's like all like
101
your belly button whoever you're built
you know when somebody laughs in the
room like if you tell a joke and we
don't laugh that means we don't like you
yeah if you tell a joke and we laugh
really really hard that means we really
really like you
if you're in a group of uh people and
someone is talking you can tell how
everyone feels about that person if
they're actually facing them
so this is all like
taking it back for sure like there's
another one this next one it says
staring i was secretly seeing a guy in
school and as far as everyone else was
concerned we couldn't stand each other
one day after class this girl i barely
knew pulled me aside and whispered i
don't know what's going on between you
you two but you need to stop staring or
everyone else is going to know so funny
later on he wanted to know what the girl
said to me i wasn't about to admit that
she noticed my staring so i said she
thinks there's something going on with
us because you keep staring at me yeah
you slick oh funny she's like you keep
looking at me this way that's adorable
oh so cute yeah it's hard not to stare
at somebody you like
and then when you try not to stare you
look like a weirdo yeah yeah i remember
um i was
dating this guy who had a roommate that
roommate had a girlfriend right and then
i like there are times where we hang out
and like you know we're all laughing too
and he's not the [ __ ] out i'm cute
looks so cute i hold his feet when he
sleeps that's a weird cat i don't know
but i'm like we were all hanging out in
the group and we're laughing laughing
i'm looking around the room and i just
see the roommate looking at me the
roommate with the girlfriend yeah i'm
like okay and then i would laugh again i
just check and see looking at me again
i'm like okay yeah it's going on here
and then um so after me and this guy
broke up you know obviously like i don't
talk to the roommate and whatever the
girlfriend and i were always so cool and
then the roommate hit me up he's like yo
my company needs to shoot this and
whatever we're shooting for my car i'm
like cool
and then i get blown up on text by her
at like four in the morning why the [ __ ]
are you shooting with this car you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm like
what
clearly it's youtube yeah have a problem
yeah
because i was not involved in this at
all in fact girl you used to come to me
about guy problems yeah and tell me all
this [ __ ] damn there's something going
on here with youtube yeah
i don't want to be involved in this yeah
did you talk to the guy oh wait because
you're not even friends with the guy i
did that kind of like why is your girl
freaking out on me right now yeah yeah
and then she was just like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you nobody cares
about you blah blah blah
um but she was also projecting because
she got caught
she was hanging out with her
ex-boyfriend yeah she has told us like
i'm still in love with him whatever oh
damn she was having another ex-boyfriend
they got into a car accident she busted
her tooth oh yeah and so that's how she
got caught i'm like oh maybe she's just
projecting oh yeah what's up wait he's
he's still with her
yep weird
super weird
super what's that
yeah
wow yeah it's not fun being the person
that people are fighting him over or
fighting about
it sounds like you love it
it's not fun
i'll save that for a day that i feel
like tearing into somebody
but i'm taking the high road if you're
watching this because you [ __ ]
weirdos watch my [ __ ] you know it's you
it's i'm just gonna throw this out there
it is so weird
to watch
someone's work
that you don't like yeah that is weird
hate watching hate watching it's so
strange it's a really really weird thing
like thanks for the view but what's
going on what's wrong with you go find a
hobby because there's a to like a
certain extent you can admire someone
because i know that i've looked at
somebody's stuff that i
don't like because of the person that
they're talking to or because i wanted
you know to be with that person but like
i don't hate them you know what i mean
like a part of me can go i see why that
person likes you and i'm like okay i get
it but to like hate watch is weird i
think it comes from a place of like
jealousy and possession and like wanting
wanting them so much yeah that they are
not happy that they're in their lives so
then they have to
hate watch yeah or try to figure out the
why like why did that person talk to
it's so funny like um you know how
people always talk about like oh you
know they're watching me from my
instagram stories from fake accounts or
watching me from bank accounts
i just tell people like look i i have
too many followers
and it doesn't accumulate everyone so i
can't even tell that you're watching my
[ __ ] yes watch me from your main account
i can't tell it's fine if you're gonna
stalk me if you don't like me if you're
an ex-girlfriend or new girlfriend or
whatever
just watch me from your main account i
can't tell there's too much i'm not
gonna know who you are i'm not gonna
know i can't see it and i'm not saying
that in a douchebag way it's just how
instagram works yeah the only reason why
i found out that anybody was watching my
stuff was because
they brought it up oh yeah no i had i
had
someone that i used to talk to asked me
if i spoke about them on one of the
shows that i was on i was like
wait what why and they said because
their girl brought it up in a fight yeah
and i was like wait why so their girl
watches yourself
and i was like no i don't really be
putting like i don't really be putting
people [ __ ] on blast like that it's just
not my like not my style yeah and when
they had told me that i was like that's
that's weird
it
i was like oh um you can let her uh
give her a kiss on the forehead and say
yeah
it's okay we're not talking about that
but i do find it interesting and i do
think people look into that too because
they assume that um they're looking for
clues right yeah they're looking for
clues to see if they're still talking
yeah and that could be like another way
maybe that's like a new age way of to
tell if somebody's sleeping together
like to bring it back to the topic maybe
they're watching to try to see if
there's like signs right
them right like i wonder if uh they make
any references or if they post anything
about it or they bring up any stories or
they're trying to catch somebody in a
lie
so that could also be too another way to
tell if somebody is like sleeping with
you know that's a lot of energy it is
yeah but you know some people got it
yeah all these energy drinks that people
be drinking all the coffee you know
these drinks all these drinks just
giving people all the energy to stop
sponsor us
sponsor me give me give me energy
through stock thank you
if you're sleepy and you want to live a
normal life [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah drink
some cold brew
if you want to be messy and nosy it's
right
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer dude honey has
saved me so much money i've been using
honey for years it's a browser extension
but now you can use it on your phone as
well your iphone as well and basically
you just have it there and whenever you
go to checkout honey tells you whether
or not you can actually use a coupon
code to save tons of money i've saved so
much i can't even count how much money
i've saved because almost every time i
go to a checkout online i have the honey
will pop up and there's a coupon code
that saves me money so uh i don't know
it's got to be in the hundreds or maybe
even thousands over the years which is
crazy to think that i would have just
checked out normally before and not
saved all that money but yeah imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites and when you check out uh you get
just basically save money immediately
one time i kid you not i went on a site
and went to purchase it was like a
repurchase of a subscription that i was
getting and honey the coupon code made
it free so i have a year's subscription
for free that i would have paid for i
think the your subscription was 50 bucks
and it's now it was free so there you go
free money in your pocket not given to
someone else and it is totally
accredited to honey and honey doesn't
just work on a desktop it works on your
iphone uh just activate it on safari on
your phone and then you can save on the
go if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show big mood
i've never recommended something that i
don't use you can get honey for free
it's a free thing at joinhoney.com
big mood that's join honey dot com slash
big mood b-i-g-m-o-o-d
uh number 12. a bunch of us used to hang
out on a teamspeak server to play games
one day one day we were chatting when
the server admit admin just blurted out
so two of you have the same ip address
today
that's funny i don't even know that you
can look at that
i don't know what teamspeak is to speak
is like a think of it like a group voice
chat that we use on our computers to
play games with like discord every yeah
like discord oh yeah but this one's just
way simpler it's just everyone hoplin
that's what i used to use too i have no
idea and we can look at ip that's
hilarious oh my gosh so funny wow
that that would mean they would need two
computers
i mean look how many people you got girl
you have like five computers that's
totally totally possible this is true oh
that's a good one
that's funny and the way you just called
him out that's funny i like that i
wonder if they actually like he
he or she called them like the users
specifically too like further putting
them
or did they just say in general i
noticed too if you have two yeah
oh that's a good one i would have loved
to be in that room yeah yeah
oh that's team oh funny that's a good
one it's good especially if it's like
the same group of people that you're
gaming with yeah yeah
that's funny okay next one 13. sometimes
you can tell by the way they casually
appropriately touch each other in public
certain things are awkward until you
cross that line at a place i worked at
about 25 years ago my co-worker had
dropped her screwdriver and our boss
picked it up and stuck it in her pocket
later that day my buddy said she did not
flinch or look away from what she was
doing when his hand went into her pocket
his hand has been in that pocket before
oh my gosh
that's a good one yeah that's a good
observation yes yes
because even when somebody hugs you for
the first time you're a little bit like
oh you know there's like a little
hesitation or there's a reaction we're
like i wasn't expecting yeah or you know
some friends like this is fine you know
like gina and i touch each other's legs
all the time because we've been there
already so you know it's not awkward for
us but it would be strange out of the
blue yeah like
we're just touching each other i saw us
on instagram yesterday that said it was
on one of those like girl pages it's
like if you hug a girl and you sway side
to side that should count as a body how
dare you how dare you you're looking
like oh hi
yeah like that should count as a body
that you stop with her yeah like we can
tell why are you swaying side to side
for like why you look so happy one armor
actually punch her in the face yeah
prove that you're not [ __ ] her
or like wait this is a guy hugging a
girl yeah yeah she's saying if i see
myself slow if i see my man you're oh my
man hugging up
or if this [ __ ] kicks her [ __ ] leg
up yeah
that can't see the body how dare you
[ __ ] her
oh my god there's i'm a hugger i hug
everybody okay
i remember having to explain like yo
that does not mean anything i literally
hug everyone when i say hello
but now i can see
where it's like there's
a certain type of hug mm-hmm
what's up
it's always friendly yeah yeah there's
like a oh i haven't seen you in a long
time then let go but if anybody's
comfortable with putting their hands on
the lower back region oh yeah not quite
booty but lower back yeah or the soft
linger after the hand just lingers for a
little
bit you're too comfortable yeah you know
we don't like that if i only see you as
a friend i'm giving you a hearty pat on
the back
really what's up buddy inside really
yeah
i probably hug a little too long yeah i
hugged i mean i i go i i take the lead
of the person i'm hugging yeah if you're
just the kind of hugger i am yeah if
you're single like i don't care how long
i hug you if you're in a relationship i
have to respectfully hug you
you know what i'm saying like don't get
caught smelling nobody yeah damn now i
wonder now do you do you think that
you've disrespected somebody's uh
girlfriend before
no
because if i know it's a girlfriend i'm
really hyper aware of that because i
know what i look like yeah it looks like
a [ __ ]
um
so no i actively make sure like if i
know his girlfriend's coming i'm really
i don't care how long i've known you can
be my best friend yeah
um
but now i'm wondering like because i
have like best guy friends i've known
since i was like 16 that would introduce
them to my guy friends and like you know
me i don't hang out with friends very
often so i see them like what's up
yeah i wonder i'm like it makes you
think right yeah because do i do too
much
because of the homies right so there's
that there's that like you hug like you
said you follow the lead so it's like oh
we're hugging we're cool
but i
i'm thinking there are definitely some
girls that are probably mad at us for
sure
that everybody like why the [ __ ] you hug
her so long yeah if i've ever hugged
anybody too long one i'm so sorry sorry
i used to drink a lot go out and just
like really really friendly and like
they're my friends yeah but i can
understand especially with how we all
look i've been like oh
yeah but i probably hug the girl like i
tend to hug the girlfriends a little bit
longer yeah it's that baby
sometimes i wonder if i like
overcompensate and i'm too nice probably
because she doesn't freak out about me
that's i feel like that's like i've been
in a situation like that where i thought
like i'm just like i felt her energy be
weird towards me so i'm like
there's no reason to be weird i promise
you i'm yeah not even there and so i'm
like trying to and then she hates me
more
i think there's only two options when
you come when you're in that situation
of like
you have a friend and then there's the
girlfriend and depending on how well you
know the guy part of you knows if the
relationship is gonna work or it's not
and you can just like hey
we're not trying to be weird and then
you kind of just like let it play out
however it's gonna play out
or you were like
this girl did it to me we are best
friends now she was like i know you
don't like me i was like i don't [ __ ]
like you
i did not like this girl shout out to
ariel she made me be her best friend and
wait so this girl is a girlfriend of
your friend was a so she was my ex's
best friend oh okay so she was my ex's
best friend
yeah and i didn't like her from previous
because my my previous ex was a [ __ ]
and he like would always comment on her
stuff and she was a pretty girl with a
big old butt so i was like i don't like
you um and then because he like sparked
up insecurity within you one that's not
even about her it was yeah that that it
was just like he was as i said he was a
[ __ ] um and then my ex and they were
best friends and he's not a [ __ ] and i
was like i just don't like you and i was
very vocal about not liking someone i
don't play nice i'm just like nah hey
you should go away
now
she's like you're gonna like me i'm like
no i'm not you psycho
and then one day she literally pulled me
inside she's like hey i'm gonna let you
know don't want your man don't watch
your man don't want him at all don't see
him that way he's not my type
but we're gonna be friends i'm like
you're psycho she's like yes i am
and
you're gonna like me because we get
along and we think the same way and
we're gonna be friends so she did the
like no
you're gonna become comfortable with me
because you need to see that this is not
what i want into the state that's like
my best friend are they still best
friends yeah they're still yeah they're
still best things yes me and him don't
talk anymore we're not cool but they're
still friends to where it's like
she was even debating going to his
birthday
i'm like oh
because no matter what like i we're not
on bad terms and like we're still best
friends and so it's like yeah girl like
look
we made this decision
we've been friends long enough and our
friendship isn't based on that
relationship so yeah so we do share a
best friend which is
i mean it's not awkward because we don't
care about what each other's doing so we
don't use her as a pawn to kind of tell
us what's going on but she was the prime
example of like
saying yo i really don't want your man
but that's my best friend you're going
to get over it and i'm so glad that she
did that no for sure because then in
that case like that relationship was so
important to her that it was important
to her that you liked her yeah
for sure yeah that's a that's that's the
way to handle that yeah because she made
it very clear and she knew she is
beautiful so she understood and i feel
like women do have to acknowledge
[ __ ] i'm a bad [ __ ]
so i can see why you feel some type of
way yeah and that's exactly what it was
and there are some times where we are
just a little bit oblivious to like why
would somebody feel that way about us
take accountability if you was a bad
girl and you were you know you like your
man and you as no matter how secure you
want to
claim to be we all got a little bit of
insecurities but it takes a real one to
go
yeah i don't want him yeah
and i understand i'm not going anywhere
as far as like this is my friend and i
would like to have a friendship with you
because
this is my friend i've been through that
i remember my friend he
first of all lives in a whole another
state
and i've known him since i was like 14.
and then one day i get a message from
him saying hey uh
i gotta not talk to you for a while i'm
like we haven't talked in like six
months bro like we just text and make
sure like you're good whatever yeah i'm
like okay that's fine like why he goes
because i have this girlfriend and for
some reason she just [ __ ] zeroed in
on me
and then
so for like the next few months or so it
went from
hey i can't talk to you too hey i gotta
unfriend you and block you
i'm like but i'm understanding i'm like
dude it's fine whatever yeah you know
like i must let you know right now
this is probably not the kind of
relationship you want to be in yeah um
and he and i have never done anything we
never hooked up or anything right and
then it went from that to hey she's
going to message you
what i'm like okay
and so she messaged me she's like hey um
i'm a friend of so-and-so okay
and he just wanted me to let you know
that he doesn't see any value in your
relation or in your friendship anymore
so he doesn't want to be friends with
you anymore what like he let her do that
no way
young and dumb you know like he's young
and dumb yeah and then
it went from that to
like he messaged me apologizing like you
don't have to apologize i get it you
know like i understand like sometimes
we're insecure they're you know it
happens when i was young i was like that
too
and then
it went to
randomly at three in the morning i get a
message from her saying you win
like i didn't even know i was playing
i was in this room no idea do you know
why do you know you know what it was
right do you still talk to this guy yeah
we're friends he's in love with you
exactly no no no no
no he
there's something off he's in there's
some but there's something somewhere off
yeah so i we we
this is that's a whole episode yeah
that's a whole mystery
tina
you are an unreliable source because i
have personally witnessed personally
myself witness
more than one guy drool over you and
you're like no no no there's no way he
likes me no way if we on the same page
we're on the same page he's in love with
you he's in love with you he said did
something to make her feel uncomfortable
about it he did it
he did it not you so here's the thing
we've known each other since we were 14
we have even more reasons to be in love
with you we rarely even talk about that
he loves you
she messaged me she's like you win i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
dude no she has issues yeah well yeah
she has issues but
he said something yes to make her feel
insecure about you yes he did it
there's no like out of the blue
your friends and she's insecure so she
said it was like he would rather
keep your friendship yep than her
relationship with me yeah i told her i'm
like yo woman woman
nothing has ever happened to me and him
when we're just friends and i think
you're kind of overreacting right now
because i don't even talk to this guy
dude he's not with him two states away
he's saving you in his mind and she
picks up on it yeah so here i'm going
with that's i'm putting
like you're the one that like secret uh
guilty pleasure yeah something there's
no way he'll ever go with the girl that
looks like you or is like anywhere
remotely like you because you're the
only one that's you yep
well we'll dive deeper into that
so you want to know
[Music]
so that girl is thinking she's picking
up on all the signs that they [ __ ] right
she's just nope gina over here giving
out mixed signals
you know here sending smoke signals this
supposed to be sos help me she's a
sinning
brother okay that's fine okay good so
yeah no he wants more reason
even more reason
we'll talk about later and i know this
because i like i said i've witnessed
multiple men multiple people talk about
this because i only know of one
well i'm here all day today yeah there's
multiple girls at least
we need to talk about like how to know
if someone's in love with you yeah wow
i'm really bad at these signals man yeah
well all right there's still plenty more
on this list which if you're curious you
can check it out in the link in the
description but that's it for this
episode thank you so much for watching
you guys make sure to check out nikki
blades and all her stuff all the time
tell them where they can find you we
have 997 now big bay mornings in the bay
area or online line at 997 now.com uh
you can check me out on the no chaser
podcast shout out to tim and rick um you
can
i just do a lot of stuff okay so
yeah follow me on instagram at nikki
blaze and stay up to date on all of them
things and she got a nice booty okay
thank you love you make sure to check
out our sponsors to support that to
support i can't speak to support this
show thank you so much we love you we'll
see you in the next episode
[Music]
so
[Music]